bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 21 février
trente mille albanais en marche pour
tenter un passage en force à mitrovica
au kosovo une ville qu'ils veulent
réunifiée contre la communauté serbe
la population iranienne votent
massivement pour les réformateurs ceux
ci possèdent déjà la majorité absolue au
parlement à l'issue du premier tour des
élections législatives
hier sept morts en quatre mois
l'épidémie de listériose suscite toutes
les craintes dans les dix-neuf
départements touchés nous évoquons les
contrôler les enquêtes en cours le
respect de la chaîne du froid nous
proposerons cité mais d'une personne
atteinte par la listériose un cas de
vache folle dans le département de l'ain
et c'est plus de 600 bêtes abattues un
tel cas s'était produit il ya deux ans
dans la sarthe chez des éleveurs qui
aujourd'hui raconte retour sur une
défaite les anglais vainqueurs des
français en rugby samedi utiliserait de
la créatine produits interdits à la
vente en france
est ce une potion magique enquête dans
ce journal koffi olomide a rempli bercy
le chanteur zaïrois surnommé papa
bonheur ou tino rossi numéro en afrique
vient de sortir un nouvel album intitulé
attentats tout a commencé tôt ce matin à
partir de pristina au kosovo quelques
milliers de personnes se sont mises en
marche en direction de mitrovica des
enfants des femmes des hommes quelques
milliers puis 10000 20000 30000 un
cortège de drapeaux albanais mais aussi
américains ceux de l'otan ou de l'onu
avec pour but passé le pont de mitrovica
qui relie des zones albanaise et serbe
la force internationale de paix la kfor
les attendait sur le pont récit ge money
un cordon de soldats de la paix contre
trente mille albanais du kosovo
difficile de contenir la colère de ces
hommes qui ont décidé de reprendre le
quartier nord de la ville habités par
les serbes
même les gaz lacrymogènes ou du mal à
calmer leurs ardeurs
depuis ce matin ils convergent de la
capitale régionale cristina mais aussi
de la vallée de la drée nitza fief
traditionnel de la guérilla de lui c'est
à leur objectif faire de mitrovica une
ville entièrement albanaise de l'autre
côté de la rivière quelques centaines de
serbes présents découdre pour défendre
leurs quartiers entre les deux pour
éviter le pire des soldats anglais
quelque peu désemparé on apporte les
gourdins en première ligne puis on les
remet dans le blindé ordre contre ordre
ces sommes ne sont pas préparés à ce
genre de missions de police
ils ont tout fait pour éviter le contact
visuel entre albanais et serbes
mais en vain dans le même temps les
hommes de la kfor ratisse mitrovica
maison par maison à la recherche d'armes
il y a eu dix morts depuis le début du
mois dans des incidents entre albanais
et serbes pour les nations unies c'est
une priorité d'obliger tous les kosovars
à vivre ensemble d'éviter que mitrovica
ne devienne le symbole d'une partition
du kosovo entre les serbes au nord et
les albanais au sud
la manifestation désormais achevée et
maintenant des milliers de personnes
retournent leurs prix shinhan ponsinet
vous êtes parmi cette foule de
manifestants qui retournent vers
prestine à qu'est ce que vous voyez que
comment est le la situation actuelle qui
a conversé aujourd'hui vers mitrovica et
qui reprend maintenant la route de
christina qu'est ce que c'est totalement
congrès de bus de voitures et de
marcheurs certains devront refaire les
30 kilomètres à pied ça signifie en tout
cas que la manifestation a pu être
dispersés à mitrovica selon la kfor la
zone des ponts la plus critique celle
qui sépare la ville en deux et
maintenant calme et sous contrôle
le couvre-feu qui prendra 6 pc à 18
heures a été repoussée pour permettre
l'évacuation la de la foule cette foule
immense trente mille marcheurs dans un
premier temps et au final peut-être même
cent quinze mille personnes à mitrovica
ça constitue un vrai succès pour la
communauté albanaise elle montre que
même démilitarisé
cette communauté albanaise conserve
larmes de la mobilisation populaire
merci à mon ciné vous étiez en direct
donc entre mitrovica est destiné à la ou
les manifestants refusent actuellement
comme un voile qui se lève sur l'iran
même timide même progressif le vote de
la population iranienne
hommes et femmes en faveur des candidats
réformateurs a déjà donné à l'issue du
premier tour hier une majorité absolue
pour ce camp réformateur
patrice romedenne commente ces résultats
les résultats définitifs des
législatives ne seront connus que dans
quelques jours
mais d'ores et déjà la victoire des
réformateurs ne souffre aucune
contestation et le président khatami qui
n'augurait aujourd'hui le métro de
téhéran se félicite de ce qu'il appelle
un nouveau chapitre en or de l'histoire
du pays les chiffres les réformateurs
rafle 178 des 290 sièges que compte le
parlement iranien majorité absolue et ce
avant même le second tour programmé pour
le mois d'avril
ce qu'il est désormais convenu d'appeler
un raz-de-marée des fermes sur les
principales villes du pays
ispahan qu'émane tabriz shiraz
bandar-abbas ahwaz machhad et la
capitale téhéran où les réformateurs
s'offre 28 des 30 sièges de députés en
jeu paradoxalement liasse de fief du
président leur échappe le taux de
participation 80 % ajoute à l'éclat de
la victoire qui doit beaucoup aux
milieux démocrates aux femmes et aux
jeunes qui n'ont connu que le régime
islamique alors que ce soit à paris
berlin et washington on constate la
volonté de changement et d'ouverture
vers la démocratie manifesté par les
électeurs iraniens mais pour autant je
marque il ouzou qui est atterrant est-ce
que tout va changer du jour au lendemain
et bien claude beaucoup de choses vont
changer en iran les attentes en matière
de libertés politiques en matière
d'économie sont immenses elles ne
changeront pas du jour au lendemain car
n'oublions pas que si les conservateurs
ont perdu la présidence et le parlement
et bien en iran au dessus de la
présidence au dessus du parlement il ya
le pouvoir religieux qui contrôlent
encore qui contrôlera la police la
justice l'armée
la télévision mais désormais
ce dont la légitimité révolutionnaire
remonte à 79 devront partager cette
légitimité avec la légitimité
démocratique sortie des urnes alors une
indication de climat si vous voulez bien
claude ce soir à téhéran dans les rues
dans les cafés dans les administrations
on sent bien que les iraniens
contiennent leur joie avec un mélange de
prudence et de maturité politique
en attendant que les résultats soient
proclamés définitivement par exemple les
réformistes ont prévu de ne pas faire de
manifestations de rue de peur de
s'attirer une provocation de la part des
groupes extrémistes islamistes qui vous
en souvenez en juillet avait tiré sur la
foule
en revanche il compte organiser dans les
prochains jours une manifestation de
masse au grand stade azadi de téhéran en
persan has audi veut dire liberté
merci jean marc vous évoquez les
événements de l'été dernier de fait on a
noté dans la presse de téhéran
aujourd'hui la confirmation par la cour
suprême de la peine de mort infligée un
étudiant arrêté au mois de juillet 99
alors qu'ils manifestaient en faveur de
la démocratie
concernant les populations civiles en
tchétchénie la commission européenne a
fait part de son extrême préoccupation
des centaines de civils ont été refoulés
par les russes devant grozny mais
quelles que soient les critiques ou
protestation étrangères comme celle de
ses 200 artistes et intellectuels
français appelant à rompre le silence
sur les massacres russe et comparant les
actes de vladimir poutine à ceux de
staline
le président russe par intérim dans la
curée il félicite l'armée pour son
travail en tchétchénie une armée russe
qui paradait ce matin sur un aérodrome
près de grozny commentaires dorothée
olliéric la journée de l'armée russe se
doit d'être fastueuse et elle l'a été
l'aérodrome où défilent ses soldats
n'est pourtant qu'à un kilomètre du
centre dévasté de grozny là bas se
cachent encore deux à trois cents
combattants tchétchènes
mais qu'importe il nous fallait
impressionné avec ce défilé
de l'examen pour le moral des troupes et
pour convaincre son électorat du bien
fondé de sa guerre vladimir poutine a de
son côté décor et à moscou les plus
grands acteurs militaires de le message
est clair
l'opération antiterroriste comme l'on
dit toujours au kremlin est sous
contrôle et la fin du conflit pour
bientôt
la puissance de ce russe bombardait rade
village après village
l'objectif est de déloger tous les
combattants tchétchènes toujours
regroupés dans la zone montagneuse du
sud de la république caucasienne
toujours dans le souci d'améliorer son
image l'armée a également ouvert à une
équipe de journalistes russes cette
prison de cherno kosovo au nord de la
tchétchénie
selon les témoignages recueillis par les
organisations humanitaires et les
journalistes occidentaux
ici des tortures infligées aux civils
selon les forces fédérales
il ne s'agit pas d'un compte de
filtration mais d'un point de contrôle
où sont actuellement détenus sains 13
personnes des suspects qui seront
enfermés le temps de déterminer s'ils
sont ou non des combattants tchétchènes
à paris le ministère des affaires
étrangères donne des consignes d'extrême
prudence aux touristes et voyageurs en
casamance au sud du sénégal
hier soir deux ressortissants sénégalais
ont été tués et un touriste français
blessé lors d'une attaque menée par un
groupe d'homme armés c'est près de
ziguinchor en casamance
c'est une vaste alerte sanitaire qui est
lancé contre l'épidémie de listériose
qui a fait sept morts depuis près de
quatre mois en france 19 départements
sont touchés et les enquêtes
actuellement menées pour tenter de
remonter à la source de cette épidémie
sont évidemment longues et complexes
voyez le reportage de benoît thevenet
heures et david basée à bordeaux
eric de l'agneau la listériose un
travail à temps plein pour les
épidémiologistes de l'institut de veille
sanitaire
les médecins procèdent par recoupement
tous les aliments consommés par les
malades sont passés au crible
nous rencontrons deux types de
difficultés la première c'est la
dispersion de l'épidémie puisque comme
vous le savez les personnes malades sont
répartis dans 19 départements et la
deuxième difficulté c'est que les
premiers interrogatoires sur la
consommation alimentaire de ces patients
nous ont pas permis de desserrer de
repérer un un aliment responsable
et pourtant la bactérie listeria est
surveillé de près dès qu'un cas est
suspecté par un médecin la souche et
isolés par un laboratoire et envoyés à
l'institut pasteur où sont comparées et
répertorier toutes les souches de
listéria parallèlement le médecin fait
une déclaration obligatoire auprès de la
direction départementale des affaires
sanitaires et sociales
aussitôt un questionnaire alimentaire
est envoyé aux malades pour tenter de
dresser la liste des aliments à risque
à partir de là l'institut de veille
sanitaire et l'institut pasteur déclare
ou non l'épidémie si tel est le cas une
cellule de crise est activée
composé de membres du ministère de la
santé de l'agriculture et de la
consommation
elle lance deux nouvelles enquêtes
véritable travail policier
c'est inconcevable pour faire des
paiements sur tous les aliments présents
chez les distributeurs surtout les
aliments à risque de listériose il
faudrait prélever tous les fromages à la
coupe les fromages au lait cru
toutes les charcuteries donc nous notre
travail c'est de cibler ses enquêtes en
orientant sur les produits qui nous
semblent être les produits
un véhicule de la contamination ce sont
ces produits qui sont actuellement
prélevé un peu partout en france par les
inspecteurs vétérinaires pour être
analysés si cette semaine les
épidémiologistes espère pouvoir affiner
les recherches
il faudra en revanche peut-être
plusieurs semaines pour trouver
l'aliment responsable
il convient de rappeler encore que la
listériose est une maladie infectieuse
due à la bactérie listeria qui se traite
habituellement pendant trois semaines à
l'aide d'antibiotiques plus précisément
une combinaison d'antibiotiques parmi
les symptômes on constate de forte
fièvre des maux de tête ce fut le cas
pour cette femme que vous allez entendre
dans le reportage de christophe devals
en bras et alain darrigrand
elle était enceinte de six mois
lorsqu'elle a contracté la listériose au
mois de janvier en mangeant de la langue
de porc en gelée elle a passé onze jours
dans le service des urgences de
l'hôpital d'angoulême
on retiendra de son témoignage que les
dépistages tardifs peuvent être fatales
sujets à risque et à consommer de la
langue de porc en jeu les produits à
risque
mais en pleine période de grippe quand
les premiers symptômes apparaissent maux
de tête fièvre
comment faire le rapprochement avec la
listériose et le mal persiste dix quinze
jours avant que d examen pointu ne
désigne enfin la maladie le choc
vous savez quand un médecin vous
téléphone à leur domicile qui vous dit
vous rentrez aujourd'hui tout de suite
immédiatement la à la clinique en
branches opèrent avec une grosse dose ou
lentilles bio ça craint pour le débit
également pour vous aussi enfin je peux
pas m'avancer plus que ça on verra ça
tout à l'heure je peux vous dire vous
essayez pas ce que vous demandez ce qui
vous arrive
là on en entend parler énormément il ya
énormément de cas donc là on va la
prendre au sérieux
mais là c'était trop tôt et personne ne
pensait encore à la listériose qui
s'aggravait de jour en jour catherine
sera hospitalisé juste à temps sous
perfusion d'antibiotiques pendant 11
jours
elle s'en tire mais qu'en est il du bébé
qu'elle porte le risque
il dépend du terme de la grossesse en
gros
avant six mois c'est plutôt un
avortement après six mois ça va plutôt
être un accouchement prématuré
moi ce que j'ai peur c'est qu'au niveau
du développement que ce soit moteur ou
autres qu'il y ait eu un problème et que
c'est stopper le développement et qui
est un problème à la naissance et sarre
parce que ça personne ne sait réellement
le doute l'angoissé mais aussi la colère
que personne médecin pouvoirs publics
laissions pêcher cette épidémie de
listériose et ce soir l' agence
française de sécurité sanitaire des
aliments recommande l'interdiction de la
consommation des ris de veau de la rate
et des intestins pour tous les bovins
nés avant le 1er mars 98 dans les
recherches menées par les autorités
d'autres produits sont visés comme les
fromages au lait cru certaines
charcuteries comme les pâtés rillettes
ou produits en gelée ou bien encore
certains poissons fumés il ne s'agit pas
bien sûr de tout interdire mais d'être
très prudents et vigilants sur ce que
l'on appelle la chaîne du froid
voyez le reportage de gym marine eric
mézil jean-louis buissière 5h ce matin à
rungis arrivé dans la nuit des centaines
de tonnes de produits frais ils
attendent leurs destinataires dans les
bancs réfrigérée température moyenne 0
devrait et surgelés ont droit à la
chambre froide climat polaire moins 25
degrés c'est ici que les produits sont
stockés ici et après on a comme vous
avez pu le voir à l'extérieur des
meubles ou là nous faisons des
présentations petit de produits mais
tout le stockage se fait ici
et la chaîne se poursuit un magasin de
quartier à paris le rayon frais annonce
les prix bien sûr mais il affiche aussi
pour un oeil averti la température de
conservation
là c'est un indicateur de température
tout à fait une vous êtes à combien bas
0 0
en fait centre 0 e +2 et toutes les
banques sont équipés les produits sont
arrivés à 7 heures du matin entre la
sortie du camion frigorifique de
livraison et la mise en étalage une
demi-heure au plus un délai insuffisant
selon les responsables de
l'établissement auront la chaîne l'ue
font en revanche le danger peut venir
d'ailleurs de votre réfrigérateur
l'ennui effectivement c'est que la
grande majorité comme celui ci ne
comporte pas de thermomètre un petit
moyen pour le vérifier c'est par exemple
mettre un terme au met dans un verre
rempli d'eau et de regarder un petit peu
la température
sachant que selon les endroits du
réfrigérateur la température doit aussi
liée entre 2 et 8 degrés sauf dans le
bac à légumes et dans les compartiments
de la porte mais la chaîne du froid
n'est pas infaillible pas plus que
d'autres mesures d'hygiène conséquence
le risque zéro n'existe pas
le 0 hysteria à -2 d'aller vers une
nourriture conditionné aseptisé traité
dionisi le 0 hysteria c'est une illusion
l'amibe listeria devient de plus en plus
résistantes les spécialistes l'ont
constaté l'une des principales mesures
de prévention consisterait à réduire le
temps de conservation des produits sains
il va de soi mais il faut leur préciser
que dans cette affaire de listériose
aucune marque pour l'instant on est en
cause et que les images que nous
diffusions dans ses reportages ne
sauraient être utilisées contre tel ou
tel produit précisément c'est aussi au
nom du principe de précaution maximum
que la france se distingue en europe
notamment de la grande bretagne en
procédant l'abattage systématique de
tous les troupeaux l'on décèle même un
seul cas de vache folle ainsi d'un
département de l'ain une bête était
atteinte d'encéphalopathie spongiforme
bovine et
les 600 autres bêtes de l'élevage ont
été abattus on imagine le désarroi des
éleveurs dans de telles situations à
thorigné sur dué
c'est dans le département de la sarthe
en décembre 97
plus d'une centaine de bêtes ont subi le
même sort l'agricultrice a porté plainte
contre le fabricant d'aliment eric masi
et nadine picard pour france 2 ont
rencontré cette femme qui a refait pour
eux le récit de ce qu'elle a vécu
il y a deux ans pour nous là elle a même
un état qui est pas normal qu elle est à
la mairie qui est pas en état normal
la grille elisabeth ne parvient pas à
faire son deuil de cette histoire
souvent elle se repasse ses images
tournées par les services vétérinaires
on y voit l'une de ses vaches une belle
normande atteintes par la maladie de la
vache folle c'était le 10 décembre 97
quelques jours avant que tout le
troupeau ne soit abattu on nous a appris
la nouvelle à la le vendredi à 1h30 à 2
samedi soir à sept heures on avait plus
rien nous reste est du reste et nos
enfants nos chiens et nos chats
à part ça c'est tout et des bâtiments
tout neufs avec ariane dans comment
leurs vaches at-elle été contaminés
c'est ce que ne comprennent pas
elizabeth et son mari ils n'achetaient
aucune bête à l'extérieur juste de
l'aliment et puis ces farines animales
responsable de l'épidémie était
interdite depuis quatre ans quand leurs
vaches est née une seule explication
pour elisabeth les fabricants d'aliments
ont accidentellement ou non mélanger ces
farines interdite aux rations de ces
animaux je dirais que trop confiance
facilement aujourd'hui moi je dis qu'on
leur a fait confiance et repartir à zéro
tout recommencer cela n'a pas été facile
bien sûr le couple a été indemnisée
l'état s'est montré généreux et à verser
2 millions de francs de quoi racheter
130 têtes de bétail
elle intègre en afrique ronde et belle
mais même s'ils continuent d'appeler les
vaches par leur nom le coeur n'y est
plus l'attachement aux troupeaux n'est
plus le même les voisins éleveurs qui
eux aussi acheter leurs aliments à la
même coopérative ont pris peur ils ont
préféré ne pas venir voir ni savoir
moi j'ai perdu un ami il ya des gens qui
sont venus huit jours avant voir mon
bébé que je n'ai jamais revu et que je
ne reverrais jamais pourquoi je sais pas
vache folle les basques est ce qu'on est
contagieux est ce que c'est pire que
quand même qu'on ait rahou je pense
qu'une maladie mais c'est vrai que les
gens osent pas nous approcher sur plus
de 90 éleveurs français dont le troupeau
a été abattu pour cause de vache folle
elisabeth est la seule à avoir porté
plainte pour empoisonnement
elle refuse contrairement aux autres de
se taire d'endosser une responsabilité
qui n'est pas la sienne victime elle ne
veut plus passer pour coupables dans
l'aveyron les recherches des gendarmes
ont repris pour tenter de retrouver le
bébé d'un mois et demi portée disparue
depuis une semaine après la découverte
des corps de sa mère et de sa demi soeur
tués par balles flavin près de rodez
mais pour l'instant aucune piste
sérieuse a été moquée par les gendarmes
pour retrouver l'auteur de ces meurtres
des morts suspectes en prison il y en a
plusieurs dizaines chaque année du moins
s'agit-il de mort inexpliquée clairement
par l'administration pénitentiaire qui
avancent le plus souvent le terme de
suicide
dès lors qu'un détenu meurt dans une
maison d'arrêt où une centrale il y a
deux semaines c'était au quartier
disciplinaire de la maison d'arrêt de
nantes
dimanche c'était à saint quentin
fallavier dans l'isère dans les deux cas
les familles dénoncent le silence des
autorités et ne croit pas aux versions
officielles
reportage de notre correspondant en
rhône-alpes virginie pichet avec olivier
jacques alie bouchetta était arrivé
derrière ces murs quelques heures
seulement avant sa mort vendredi dans la
soirée
cet homme de 33 ans originaire de la
banlieue lyonnaise a été retrouvée dans
sa cellule
pendu à l'aide de ses lacets se
suicident sa soeur farida ne peux
toujours pas y croire
il avait le goût de vivre et il avait
fait des projets
c'était pas son tempérament quoi c'est
simple c'était pas son tempérament
c'est pour ça que pour moi j'ai accepté
pas cette histoire de suicide
ce matin des proches d'ali bouchetta ont
rencontré un responsable de la prison
les premières précisions qu'ils ont
obtenus renforcent encore leurs doutes
il y avait un détenu qui était libérable
donc qui lui a fait un message lui a dit
tu dis à ma famille que tout va bien qui
membres du linge des mandats il a m'a
mise en eau des troupes à pied trois
heures plus tard ali bouchetta était
mort plus qu'un acte désespéré ou une
pulsion incontrôlable son entourage
pense qu'il aurait pu être victime de
ses gardiens suspicion intolérable pour
l'administration pénitentiaire entre
personnel fait un métier difficile et
parfois dangereux et il le fait avec
beaucoup d'honneur donc de ce point de
vue là je refuse absolument d'entendre
dire que les surveillants sont des
assassins
c'est absolument intolérable irrecevable
l'an dernier plus d'une centaine de
suicides ont été recensés dans les
prisons françaises pour danielle gonnin
ancien coordinateur des prisons
lyonnaises le doute s'insinue trop
souvent là où le manque d'information
persiste eu le souci qu'on n'aura pas
mis en place d'une vérification
systématique de tout mon tour en prison
le vrai jeu pratiqué aujourd'hui
l'autopsié dali bouchetta elle n'a pas
encore livré ce début de réponse tant
attendue
le tribunal correctionnel de paris a
condamné à 10 ans de prison ferme deux
militants basques membres de l' eta dont
l'un daniel derguy est en grève de la
faim depuis près de deux mois pour
protester contre les conditions de son
emprisonnement d'un mandat d'arrêt pour
organisation frauduleuse d'insolvabilité
et est délivrée contre le nationaliste
corse alain orsoni par la cour d'appel
de paris alain orsoni serait
actuellement à salonique aragua et se
serait arrangé pour ne pas indemniser
les gendarmes victime d'un attentat
attentat revendiqué par le flnc les
habitudes d'opacité des directions
départementales des affaires sanitaires
et sociales ddas continue deux frères
âgés de 5 et 7 ans vivait dans une
maison d'accueil près de mazamet ch et
un couple âgé de 65 et 61 ans trop vieux
pour la dass ses parents d'accueil se
battent maintenant pour conserver la
garde des enfants aujourd'hui après un
nouvel entretien
la dass du tarn
des de repousser sa décision reportage
muriel la saga et christophe cadeaux
dans la petite maison bosquillon les
valises de pierre et michael sont restés
là depuis vendredi dernier
comme tout le monde elles attendent une
décision de l'administration qui réglera
le sort des enfants pour soutenir
marguerite et edward et voisine où des
mères qui parfois ne connaissent même
pas la famille des femmes tout
simplement les ont accompagnés jusqu'à
leur rendez vous avec l'aide sociale à
l'enfance des meubles quand il faut
réfléchir qui on lui donnait déjà et
puis on l'enlève pas comme ça du jour au
lendemain la décision tant attendue n'en
est pas vraiment une
pierre et mickaël resteront dans leur
famille d'accueil actuel jusqu'à la fin
de l'année scolaire
après on verra il sera toujours temps de
discuter
encore une fois si vous le faites c'est
le mot laissé quatre mois dans 80 ça va
être pareil dans quatre mois ils vont
être de nouveau manipuler comme de ton
plus que l'administration se retranche
derrière la loi ne pouvons pas parler
dans notamment de la durée parce que
nous ne la connaissons pas du placement
puisque je rappelle que le placement il
est pris par un magistrat qui est le
juge des enfants
au coeur de ce débat il y à ce soir deux
enfants qui eux ne savent toujours pas
où ils seront l'été prochain demain à
bruxelles devant la commission des
libertés publiques pour la première fois
dans une telle enceinte sera évoqué
l'existence d'un système mondial de
surveillance et d'interception des
télécommunications militaires et civiles
c'est un système mis au point par les
américains est baptisé du nom de code
échelon
ça fait 20 ans que ce système qui
fonctionne
pour france 2 hervé brusini a réuni
plusieurs éléments démontrant
l'importance voire le danger pour
certains de ce système dont on peut
constater la réalité derrière
l'apparence anodine d'énormes sorte de
balle de golf poser quelque part dans un
champ en grande bretagne cela tient du
film fantastique mais c'est bel et bien
une réalité à vous faire frémir ses
boules blanches ne sont là que pour
empêcher le promeneur de voir vers quoi
sont pointés les coupoles qu'elle abrite
à 280 km à l'ouest de londres
cette base dont on chercherait vainement
l'emplacement sur une carte
cette base écoute la france mais aussi
l'europe et l'afrique
tous les téléphones les fax les
ordinateurs rien n'échappe à ce
dispositif
il appartient au système d'espionnage
planétaire baptisé échelon duncan
campbell fut l'un des tout premiers à
révéler l'existence de ce maillage
mondial des télécommunications au jour
le jour ils collectent les preuves
photographiques de l'implantation
d'autres bases secrètes comme celle ci
par exemple situé au japon il en existe
d'autres encore en australie et en
nouvelle-zélande en fait c'est la terre
entière qu'on espionne
le scandale c'est que les agences de
renseignement sont hors la loi elles ne
reconnaissent aucune frontière
elles ne reconnaissent pas les droits de
l'homme voici le coeur du dispositif la
nsa l'agencé pour la sécurité nationale
près de washington
budget 24 milliards de francs l'origine
de ce réseau c'est un accord secret
signé entre les etats-unis et la
grande-bretagne en 1948 à présent ici
des ordinateurs hyperpuissant analyse
les messages sur internet les
conversations téléphoniques
ce document classé gamme a le plus haut
niveau du secret à la cia prouve qu'une
discussion entre chinois et pakistanais
étaient écoutées en 96
on y parlait d'équipements nucléaires
les français thomson csf en 94 airbus
industrie en 95 ont perdu des contrats
piéger par le système échelon mais alors
comment se préserver d'une pareille
intrusion
du coup si vous faites passer vos
communication sur fibres optiques
c'est plus difficile de les intercepter
si tout est codé avec différents niveaux
de cryptage et grâce à beaucoup
d'ordinateurs ce n'est pas difficile
alors vous bloquer leurs capacités
d'espionnage dans ce monde de l'ecoute
personne ne se fait confiance
dans son rapport comme bell met en
évidence que les anglais les américains
les deux piliers du système ne cesse de
s'espionner entre eux plusieurs
avalanches ont eu lieu ces dernières 24
heures se barre à davos en suisse il y a
trois morts et un blessé
après une coulée de neige qui a traversé
une piste de ski à la mi journée ça
c'est à davos ans norman ces images et
il ya aussi une avalanche en italie du
nord dans le haut adige trois morts et
deux blessés puis en autriche jean
tirole un garçon de 15 ans et est
également porté disparu enseveli par une
avalanche depuis dimanche premier chèque
d'indemnisation pour les victimes de la
marée noire du pétrolier erika qui a
fait naufrage 12 décembre dernier au
large du sud finistère l'assureur du
navire et le fonds d'indemnisation
viennent de donner cinq chèques cas des
pêcheurs et un propriétaire de
restaurant victime arrivée du fioul sur
les plages du morbihan et de la
loire-atlantique et pornichet mais les
chèques sont pour l'instant pas très
important aujourd'hui à vannes la
ministre dominique voynet rencontré dans
les locaux de la préfecture du morbihan
les préfets des départements concernés
les élus les associations la ministre a
mis l'accent sur les mesures de
protection concernant les bénévoles à la
critique et les organismes comme le
cèdre vous météo france mais a tenu à
rassurer les consommateurs sur la
qualité des huit qu'elle a dégusté après
cette réunion comme voici
et puis en politique c'est une semaine
décisive pour la préparation des
élections municipales à paris du côté
des socialistes bertrand delanoë
président du groupe socialiste au
conseil de paris a officiellement lancé
sa candidature à l'investiture sous le
signe dit il du renouveau il a l'appui
de plusieurs maires d'arrondissement
dont le me chercher des relations avec
le parlement daniel vaillant et le
sénateur claude estier qui était à ses
côtés quant à jacques lang il dira si
oui ou non ils quittent blois pour paris
ce sera vendredi du sport du rugby bien
sûr pas question de ne pas être
fair-play de ne pas reconnaître le
talent des anglais vainqueur des
français samedi au stade de france mais
tout de même dans les propos de
l'entraîneur français bernard laporte on
aura noté ces interrogations sur l'
usage de la créatine une substance dont
la vente est interdite en france
et qui permettrait de masques et
l'absorption de produits dopants seule
certitude la créatine est autorisé en
angleterre mais sur les effets de cette
substance s'il y a des un reportage
christelle bertrand et maryse burgot
contre l'angleterre les français
s'attendaient à un défi physique
ils ont eu le quinze tricolore n'a pas
fait le poids
aujourd'hui la préparation de l'équipe
de france est remise en cause
comme les anglais les français ne dirait
pas non à un petit coup de pouce
alimentaire on ne change pas uniquement
avec de la musculation ou avec un
préparatif un préparateur physique
maintenant qui est au top crois qu'il ya
un moment il ya des suppléments
énergétiques qui sont là pour aider à la
récupération qui sont là pour aider
aussi la masse musculaire
il utilise à l'angleterre il utilise
depuis 10h30 ce fait reçu à noël
utiliser ce supplément énergétique
magique s'appelle la créatine cette
molécule est présente dans la viande et
le poisson mais la formule concentrée se
présente en poudre
on l'apprend dilué dans de l'eau les
scientifiques français sont loin
d'adhérer aux vertus de la poudre qui
fait prendre du muscle moi je suis
sportif de haut niveau
prendre de la créatine qu'est ce que ça
va m'apporter rien rien du tout mais la
créatine peut aussi servir à masquer des
produits dopants
c'est pourquoi en france le ministère de
l'économie a résolu le problème
cette circulaire indique qu'il est
interdit de mettre en vente des produits
contenant de la créatine interdit en
france mais légal en angleterre
tellement légal que des publicités
vantent les mérites de ce produit
utilisé par des centaines de joueurs
autorisées aussi par le cio la créatine
n'a convaincu ni la commission médicale
de la fédération française de rugby ni
le sélectionneur de l'équipe de france
il faut pas le prendre parce qu'il ya
des risques physiques à terme mais je
dis nous ne prenons pas acceptant de
subir des matchs comme comme ça me dit
mais je préfère est quand même
privilégiez l'intégrité physique de mes
joueurs que le contraire à chaque
défaite de l'équipe de france
la créatine est un débat récurrent pas
sûr qu'une victoire tricolore en aurait
fait autant parler
un nouveau décès parmi les auteurs de
bande dessinée c'est will qui vient de
mourir à l'âge de 72 ans en belgique il
était le papa de tif et tondu publié par
le journal de spirou à la fin des années
alors voici quelques images il fut aussi
le créateur d'isabelle son dernier album
c'était la 27e lettre m'a qualifié
souvent wind de peintre des femmes
c'était aussi un aquarelliste koffi
olomide et plus prophète en son pays
originaire de l'ex zaïre il est un
musicien reconnu sur tout le continent
africain noir pour le qualifiant d'
utiliser surnom de papa bonheur papa
sucre ou encore de professeurs des
élèves voire de tino rossi africain il
est entouré de sapeurs membres de la
sape est aps société des ambianceurs et
des personnes élégantes disons que ce
sont des costumes brillants chic et cher
auquel michel mompontet mahdi diawara
n'ont pas été insensibles lors du
concert unique que koffi olomide a donné
à bercy à paris honte ont commencé par
une présentation pour éviter tout bla
bla du roi black lui c'est anelka a le
transfert le plus cher de l'histoire du
foot et de la musique vrai en afrique
c'est lui le 70ème de messi et même
comme la chaîne de personnes wallace et
les rares personnes coincées là lui
c'est rick hanson eric tutsi d'angle
prof de chant championnes sont un petit
bout eh ouais
à lubjana
depuis trois semaines venus de kinshasa
ils vivent autour du roi koffi dans
cette salle de répétition leur défi
transformer paris en capitale du congo
une nuit durant
dans 24 heures ce sera à bercy
et pour la première fois une star
africaine qui va tenter de remplir les
vingt mille sièges le tout sans avoir
jamais fait la moindre émission de télé
en france ni la moindre couverture de
magazine thoumin quintin les en afrique
ses chansons d'amour qu'annoncé et
langoureuse sont déjà depuis longtemps
des classiques
au total
- commune ce sont elles les femmes
africaines qui l'ont élu roi roi de
coeur bien sûr
les femmes savent reconnaître les gens
qui les aiment vraiment je pense que m
me repérer
je pense souvent à dire que j'y viens
les âmes tout simplement
mais sincèrement moi on m'a demandé une
fois ci alessio lalime a eu sur la lune
m'intéresserait cas où ça devenait
payant
j'ai dit qu'il y aurait pas des femmes
là-bas générés par bercy 23h des femmes
et la mode africaine ouvre le bal comme
un hommage voir une invitation
koffi olomide lui dans sa loge a revêtu
son pantalon de diamants et argent pris
47 mille francs le luxe comme un pied de
nez et dans la salle des coffee est font
monter le thermomètre
puis à la descente comme ça retour en
loge l instant de gloire du maître de
cérémonie publique parce que moi
j'avance je demande au public de
regarder
il est 1h30 du matin tu sens que tu
commences à un public comme ça démarre
pas fini
devant 20000 fans survoltés la fusée
koffi pts atterrir pari réussi
le concert s'est achevé à 6 heures du
matin quand on vous dit que les absents
ont toujours tort
voilà pour les absences sa peur ou non
voici donc le cd de koscielny des
attentats qui vient de sortir c'est le
nouvel album voilà nous arrivons à la
fin de cette édition je vous rappelle
deux événements d'actualité que nous
avons évoqué la marche de plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'albanais de
pristina vers mitrovica au kosovo cet
après midi pour tenter d'envahir toute
la ville de mitrovica y compris la zone
serbe
la manifestation a été empêchée par la
kfor ce soir les manifestants les
dizaines de milliers ont peint jusqu'à
100000 personnes reviennent dans le
calme vers pristina
et puis l'enquêté continue pour
déterminer l'origine de l'épidémie de
listériose qui viennent provoquer cette
man 4 mois en france déconseille
d'extrême prudence sont formulées par
les autorités sanitaires
la météo dans quelques secondes avec
sophie davant et puis ensuite le
magazine de jean luc delarue jour après
jour qui sera consacrée à l'illettrisme
à suivre mots croisés magazine présenté
par arlette chabot et alain duhamel qui
réunira des invités comme marc blondel
ou edouard balladur notamment sur le
thème des retraites à zéro heure
quarante vous retrouverez laurence
ostolaza pour le dernier journal de la
rédaction
demain c'est 1,50 dans les 4 vérités
françoise laborde recevra alain mais de
là à 13h20 plaisir de retrouver ici même
carole gaessler et rachid arhab à demain
20h bonsoir merci
autre